a mixture of relief and disbelief
as two weeks of lockdown are lifted in
rio de janeiro
one of the worst coronavirus hit cities
in brazil
the good news is that by enforcing the
14 day epidemiological period suggested
by specialists
plus other restrictions we managed to
lower the number of people seeking the
city's basic health system
yet for the past week across brazil
there have been an average of four
thousand deaths a day
adding to a total of more than 350 000
second in the world only to the united
states
health experts say much more needs to be
done to curb the spread
we can't sleep because we don't know if
we'll be able to attend to the patients
if we will have medicines oxygen today
we have them but if these cases continue
growing
at some point it will be chaotic there
is no other way we don't sleep today's
reality that health workers don't rest
chile despite a vigorous vaccination
campaign has also seen a recent surge in
covet 19 cases
coming a few weeks after restrictions
were lifted to encourage
tourism in the pacific resort of vina
del mar and the nearby port city of
valparaiso
we believe that this increase is
directly related to several factors
but one of them is the holiday permit
which allowed a significant number of
people to travel to districts in our
region in a festive spirit
a spirit of rest relaxation and
disconnection after a very bad year
uruguay has also extended lockdown
restrictions
until the end of april to contain a
surge in covet 19 cases
while here in argentina we've seen a
record number of daily infections
and a new set of restrictions including
a nighttime curfew
people aren't going to tolerate being
locked up again like last year many
people want to go out
they don't want to let their children or
their family go hungry they need to look
for their daily bread
vaccines are being applied but many
complain there are too few
and new batches are not arriving fast
enough
but until those vaccination programs
start to take effect
the only other option if overburdened
health systems are to cope
is to impose ever more lockdown
restrictions
but with people tired angry and defiant
those measures are proving to be
increasingly
ineffective daniel schweiner al jazeera
buenos aires